[Musique]
france 2022 l'heure du choix comme
chaque jour c'est le moment de revenir
sur la campagne pour l'élection
présidentielle sans h rennes verdien
mais qui sera de retour parmi nous dès
demain à onze jours du second tour en
tout cas les deux finalistes font assaut
de propositions après les institutions
hier et est ce que je serai en cas
d'accession à l'elysée sa manière de
gouverner marine le pen a voulu à
nouveau rassuré aujourd'hui cette fois
sur sa politique étrangère alors qu
emmanuel macron lui se pose en dernier
garant de l'union européenne et que dans
le camp du faiseur de rois le troisième
homme de cette présidentielle jean luc
mélenchon et bien on lance une grande
consultation pour déterminer quelle sera
la consigne de vote bilal taravel
revient pour nous sur cette journée en
images
c'est l'histoire d'une france qui
jouerait sa partition en solo au sein
d'un concert des nations
marine le pen exposé son programme en
matière de politique étrangère sortie du
commandement intégré de l'otan et
scénarios post guerre en ukraine je me
prononcerai en faveur de la mise en
oeuvre d'un rapprochement stratégique
entre l'otan et la russie comme cela
avait été naguère envisagée c'est
l'intérêt de la france et de l'europe et
la candidate est reine le répète
contrairement à 2017 elle ne veut pas de
fric site
nous sommes tous des défenseurs de
l'europe et moi je considère que
transformer l'union européenne en
alliance européenne des nations c'est
sauver l'euro
emmanuel macron pas convaincu et presque
vaches et l'alliance européenne des
nations ça reste un frais xix aiguisé ne
laissez pas s'installer ni en france ni
ailleurs
des projets qui sans le dire ou en le
disant propose de sortir de l'europe la
foule aux pieds la fragilise
le président candidat a brandi la menace
d'un basculement de la france vers un
état autoritaire en cas d'arrivée au
pouvoir de marine le pen
malgré tous les efforts le vrai visage
de l'extrême droite revient c'est un
visage qui ne respectent pas les
libertés le cadre constitutionnel
l'indépendance de la presse et des
libertés fondamentales des droits du
roman est chèrement acquis qui sont au
coeur de nos valeurs comme l'abolition
de la peine de mort ou la candidat du
rassemblement national veut-elle
vraiment rétablir la peine de mort
la réponse est ambigu et elle vient du
président de son parti
vous posez à la peine de mort est
favorable à l'instauration de la
perpétuité réelle en revanche que nous
défendons c'est l'instauration dans la
constitution du référendum d'initiative
citoyenne sert qu'à partir du moment où
les français le peuple français veut se
saisir d'un sujet qui peut être un sujet
de société eh bien il se réunit cinq
cent mille signatures et cela déclenche
un référent jean luc mélenchon ouvre
aujourd'hui la grande consultation de
ses soutiens pour savoir ce qu'ils
comptent faire au second tour son
directeur de campagne se permet un
conseil à emmanuel macron
franchement des gens qui sont battus
pour que la retraite soit à 60 ans à
taux plein vous entendez bien que c'est
pas parce qu'on va dire 64 plutôt que 65
que ça va les convaincre si emmanuel
macro veut faire un geste dans cette
direction qu'il abandonne tout
simplement sa réforme des retraites
et voilà c'est donc fini pour
aujourd'hui à demain
abstention vote blanc ou bulletins
emmanuel macron pour les électeurs du
premier tour de jean luc mélenchon
réponse donc samedi après 20 heures pour
connaître l'issue de cette consultation
est donc la consigne de vote pas de
consignes de vote en revanche du côté de
l'église de france n'est pas vraiment
une surprise
la conférence des évêques rappellent
tout de même aux catholiques
l'importance d'aller voter dans un
discours prononcé vendredi son président
monseigneur eric de moulins beaufort lui
rappeler toutefois que la france ne se
définit pas par la nostalgie de ses
grandes heures passées ni ne se grandit
en prétendant s'entourer de murs manière
d'envoyer des signaux à l'électorat
catholique
et puis cette fois c'est vraiment sans
surprise les sages de la rue montpensier
valide définitivement les résultats du
premier tour c'est laurent fabius le
président du conseil constitutionnel qui
les a annoncées pour rappel le taux
d'abstention s'établit à 26,31 % de
l'électorat parmi les suffrages exprimés
emmanuel macron totalise 27 85 % contre
23 15% pour marine le pen les deux
candidats face à face avec pour l'heure
toujours un léger avantage au président
sortant dans les enquêtes d'opinion la
dernière en date celle de notre
partenaire ipsos oprah steria elle donne
emmanuel macron gagnant au second tour
avec 55% des voix contre 45% à marine le
pen dix points d'écart c'est de plus que
durant le week-end par le même institut
l'abstention elle est attendue à à 27%
très proche donc du premier tour marine
le pen qui n'entend donc sortir
de l'union européenne ni même de l'otan
juste du commandement intégré est là a
précisé aujourd'hui lors d'une
conférence de presse pour présenter sa
feuille de route en matière en matière
de politique étrangère clovis casali
étaient sur place pour france 24
est pas de sortie
clovis casali
une conférence de presse consacrée à
l'international et marine le pen sommé
de s'expliquer sur ses relations avec la
russie elle a cherché à prendre ses
distances vis-à-vis de vladimir poutine
déclarant qu'elle ne l'avait rencontré
qu'une seule fois c'était en 2000 à 17
avec la guerre qui fait rage en ukraine
on l'a interrogé sur l'aide apportée aux
ukrainiens et elle nous a confié à et
bien qu'elle était prête si elle était
élue présidente à fournir des armes
défensives et du renseignement seulement
aux ukrainiens qui combattent les russes
mais rien qui puisse faire de la france
un belligérant marine le pen la
candidate du rassemblement national a
aussi parlé d'un rapprochement entre
l'otan et la russie une fois cette
guerre finie une perspective assez
difficile à imaginer actuellement avec
certainement une opposition des pays
baltes ou d'autres pays d'europe de
l'est marine le pen donc qui a essayé de
parler internationale pendant cette
conférence de presse éclaircir un peu
quelques sujets est à noter à la fin de
cette conférence de presse un incident
avec trois activistes dans la salle une
jeune femme qui a brandi une pancarte
avec un coeur à l'intérieur une photo de
vladimir poutine et de marine le pen et
un autre activiste qui a saisi le
microphone faisant semblant d'être un
journaliste de rechute ou die de rt et
demandant à marine le pen pourquoi elle
ne répondait plus aux appels de vladimir
poutine le président russe une
conférence de presse qui a terminé de
manière un petit peu chaotique pour la
candidate de l'extrême droite qui a donc
rappelé que ce qui devait compter
c'était seulement les intérêts de la
france et que donc un rapprochement avec
la russie était possible mais seulement
si c'était l'intérêt de la france voilà
pas de sortie de l'otan pas de sortie de
l'union peine pas de sortie non plus de
l'accord de paris sur le climat pour
marine le pen en cas d'élection elle dit
vouloir abandonner le plus possible les
énergies fossiles au profit du nucléaire
civil est la candidate du rassemblement
national qui précise toutefois que la
crise climatique ne constitue pas la
priorité de sa politique étrangère est
au coeur de la politique étrangère
justement y est l'engagement européen de
la france caroline de camaret vous êtes
notre spécialiste des questions
européennes ce second tour c'est d'abord
de vie l'europe qui s'affrontent avec
emmanuel m'a conquis dès son élection
est à nouveau dans les 4 vérités 1,7 et
ce matin sur france 2 a rappelé combien
l'europe est au coeur de son projet pour
la fouiller alors d'ailleurs puisqu'il
veut jouer non pas la diabolisation mais
programme contre programme regardant ce
programme européen qui est finalement le
plus clivants avec marine le pen de tous
les chapitres de son programme puisque
emmanuel macron il vise à rendre
l'europe puissante si on regarde
effectivement ces trois grands mots
d'ordre finalement par rapport au thème
européen l'europe puissance donc d'abord
qui est là d'ailleurs la devise de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne et qui finalement n'est pas
du tout celle de son adversaire y des
européistes convaincu on voit des
drapeaux européens dans tous ses
meetings et cette europe qui est la
nôtre n'est pas une alliance de nations
qui veulent se faire la guerre mais un
projet de respect qui a mis fin au rêve
d'empyr précise-t-il il a jugé
d'ailleurs globalement l'europe trop
absence de la campagne lors de son
déplacement dans le finistère et puis
l'a été aussi hier à strasbourg il a
cité l' indépendance énergétique face à
la russie que son adversaire jugent
coûteuse en termes de pouvoir d'achat ou
la politique de défense européenne une
politique de défense renforcée au coeur
de l'otan et ça aussi ça pose problème
après marine le pen et puis il termine
en disant que la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme qui
fait respecter dont sexe est les
principes de droits de l'homme justement
et bien il ne veut pas lui en sortir à
la différence de marine le pen alors
justement marine le pen à elle prône un
programme de franche rupture sur la
question européenne voilà de franche
rupture moins évidemment que
précédemment elle a renoncé quand même à
l'idée du fch exit de sortir et de
l'euro et de l'union européenne mais
elle veut une alliance européenne des
nations c'est son nom c'est son motto
son mot d'ordre finalement et ça
consiste par exemple à des processions
qui reste contraire aux traités
européens comme une renégociation des
accords de schengen pour instaurer plus
de contrôles de frontières donc
intérieur à cet espace schengen elle
parle aussi d'une supériorité du droit
constitutionnel français
or le droit européen ce qui pose
problème en pologne ça a été puni
effectivement part
et d'ailleurs des pôles hommes les
polonais ont dû se rétracter sur cela
puisque ça n'est pas le cas et puis elle
veut renégocier les traités dans un
esprit finalement qui qui pourrait qui
pourrait faire penser à celui qui a
précédé le breakbeat surtout sur la
question du craignent-elles le rôle de
l'union européenne n'est pas totalement
le même que celui d' emmanuel macron en
effet elle a été reçue par le chef du
kremlin en 2017 tandis que son parti
continue à rembourser un emprunt de 9
millions d'euros contractée en 2014 et à
linverse du président sortant elle
milite pour une sortie de la france on
l'a dit du commandement intégré de
l'otan et surtout une stratégie entre
l'otan et la russie
effectivement qui serait favorisée par
l'union européenne une stratégie commune
qui paraît en effet difficile à mettre
en oeuvre merci car lieu juste en deux
mots les les arguments qui vont
s'échanger alors justement emmanuel
macron va jouer sur son sur ce profil
plus proche de poutine mais il ya un
risque pour lui parce que finalement il
veut aussi draguer les électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon qui peut-être sont
sensibles à certains arguments de
footing et marine le pen elle va
attaquer le président français justement
sur son amour de l'europe et sur sa
présidence française de l'union
européenne qui lui aurait donné plus de
temps de parole par exemple elle va elle
va aussi l'attaqué sur les traités
européens nous comme le ceta les grands
traités
qui ont un impact environnemental bref
effectivement la nation qui protège
contre une europe omnipotente c'est le
programme de marine le pen l'europe qui
protège pour hisser la nation au niveau
des grandes puissances ça c'est le
programme d' emmanuel macron merci
caroline de camaret spécialiste des
questions européennes sur france 24 gros
plan à présent sur les militants et les
airs ils sont les grands naufrages et de
dimanche dernier privé de second tour
pour la deuxième fois d'affilée est
désormais en péril financier les jeunes
sont bien souvent déboussolés face au
manque de consignes claires venues du
sommet reportage de karina chahbour
au lendemain de la déroute historique de
valérie pécresse les jeunes républicains
sont partagés le parti appelle à ne
donner aucune voix à marine le pen e
votre ou emmanuel macron au nom du front
républicain
aujourd'hui pour moi votre second tour
j'écoute ce qu'elle a dit dimanche dans
son discours
son discours aux valeurs chiraquienne
qui dit du refus des extrêmes et moi ma
droite à moi c'est celle là c'est celle
qui refuse de travailler les extrêmes et
donc c'est pour ça que je voterai pour
emmanuel macron je dirais que c'est bien
sûr un vote de raison un vote de
responsabilité pour empêcher l'extrême
droite d'arrivée au pouvoir et aussi en
tant que jeune de 21 ans pour avoir une
société apaisée qui s'est discuté des
batteries qui ne se fait pas dans la
violence ou l'opposition
la fiche du second tour n'emballe pas
non plus ses militants de l'est de la
france téléphone
encore de choix décidé donc soit un vote
blanc soit vote par défaut contenu du
programme économique du manuellement je
pense sérieusement voté blanc c'est pas
assez le choix de facilité
mais
mais je me vois pas non plus voté pour
l'un ou pour l'autre
raphaël rosa n'est pas une militante
comme une autre elle à l'investiture et
l'air dans la 8e circonscription de
moselle avec kevin schwenzer son
suppléant il espère reprendre ce
territoire conquis par la majorité
présidentielle il y a cinq en tout cas
on fera tout pour avoir un maximum un
maximum de sièges à l'assemblée pour
pouvoir justement montrer que le parti
est uni que le parti vit encore et que
voilà les élus
les élus sont là pour montrer à la force
du parti
les républicains qui jouent leur survie
espère bien conserver leur sang un
député à l'issue des législatives de
juin
et france 2022 l'heure du choix c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui vous retrouverez h
rennes verdure à mes côtés demain on se
retrouve dans un instant pour un nouveau
journal dans moins de trois minutes
rester avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]